[Music]
good evening everybody welcome to our
first choice lesson tonight and
hopefully we're going to really enjoy
analyzing a couple games and I welcome
to ask your questions and the life
together so let's start with the first
game the first game was played by Ethan
with white and he will keep hearing the
audience who will be helping me with the
most and again if you have any questions
just ask and let's analyze together so
even let's start with the first move
efore so I'll answer before we start can
you let us know which tournament was it
and what was your opponent so Ethan he's
about 1600 and he played the guy who was
about 1780 so and did you win the game
so even played with wirings who won the
game against a stronger opponent so
let's see how it all went okay so which
is Sicilian awesome okay takes takes a 6
ok let's stop here so your opponent
played a 6 and basically he kind of
identified the structure so he plays
false and variation of Sicilian and then
besides a 6 could have played nicely 6
that's another line and here there is a
big choice in front of white so you guys
know what is what are the most popular
most here what would you suggest as
white
nice 93 right that's probably the most
popular rule and c4 right so nice a 3
and C 4 and other another move that is
very popular any suggestions it can
Bishop this ring right so basically here
we're talking about Bishop d3 93 and c4
3 moves how did you continue Bishop
different9 f6
okay well Sicilian is a complicated
opening you have to know so many lines
in the Sicilian so it's very hard work
it's not that you just study three lines
and you're good to go you know that
world champions played Sicilians one of
the most popular openings I played to
fill in all my life and that's one of my
favorite openings and actually I play
Paulson myself is black so in this
position well besides negative six first
of all there are other most like Bishop
c5 responsible here then you can play
all night of six hours really but I
would say the shift to five has been one
of the most popular moves and then sits
93 and then here probably you know
Bishop to e7 or Bishop to e7 to most
here possible and you know the theory
doesn't stop developing and typically
different most even including like 97 96
so it's just really the matter of choice
but the main moves that you should know
is Bishop c5 after night before you
retreat to b7 and then eight seven and
then the other move like what even
played Knight of 6 I'm sorry your
opponent played not nurture you played
the right so here you continued with a
three okay so what was the thread that
she decided to continue with a three so
you played a three how did your opponent
respond
93 so really a dream you don't need that
move so going forward
you can just respond for it either see
493 or just Castle probably be easiest
if you didn't like Bishop before just
calculate here and then really there is
no sense to play Bishop before because
after you cut out your king he cannot
spoil opinion okay Bishop c5 he
continued it's really bishop based on so
he's really do you ever think right he's
not doing anything extraordinary not
playing d5 too early or d5 too early to
develop his pieces nice ring coincidence
okay really with the bishop on a7 you
see that a3 was the loss of temple right
because nobody really thread into the
before and it's just the loss of tempo
okay how did you continue what did you
decide on to play Bishop g5 first digit
Castle short side what did you choose
Bishop g5 over customer because alone
said okay that explains that so you
wanted to cut alongside okay excuse me
root g8 that's how she played
interesting okay so let me try to think
it's black why would I want to play root
g8 so probably counting that my opponent
would take on a6 then I would take and I
would open the G file right would you
guys think why would one play ugh well
that's the only idea I can find how to
explain Oh Jade so what do you think
what do you think instead of route 8 how
can black continue here what what should
you do
because rotate is really not the best
move let's put it this way move the
knife where would you move the night
not that easy to move the knife because
for instance h5 is controlled by the
Queen like d5 you can't move only like
g8 which is pretty bad so that doesn't
work just nice to fix continued
development yeah that's another you
right Ethan that's one of the common
positions in the Sicilian it's black
that black would allow this double
points on the F file and then after that
just most likely the King State in the
center when he plays d6 Bishop d7 so
let's go back to this position was there
any better move that just before Bishop
g5 happened kind of maybe just simply d6
right
that was another mouth like here
displayed d6 and then if I play Bishop
g5 Knight d7 and then you're free to
develop your queen and you don't have to
worry about not being able to castle
right so after Queen c7 well Bishop g5
is kind of you want to play Bishop g5 to
Texas this night and of course after
routiers you're very happy to see that
move right weren't you
right so basically actually played a3
and realize that there's a lot of tempo
and then your opponent plays rubgy
you're kind of thinking wow
it wasn't that bad so that compensated
did you take on a fix good okay Spacek
elite a can affixed again you justified
it route g8 which is really a little bit
off here oh okay
we'll see
22 we have a choice between Queen e2 and
Queen d2 here right
ninety-four agree okay so it's going to
294 and then let's show it to everybody
then you have to think how to defend
upon you can probably retreat here right
and then protect the pawn on f2 but
still you're given that option to the
knight to be on e5 to be in the center
and then not necessarily really like
that so Queen it feels perfect yeah just
great move Queen e2 okay blonde said
castle how did you continue might be
done okay let's stop here for a second
so you know as any position any opening
you develop the bases you castled
and then every opening is different
because you have certain ideas that I
described that this of that opening so
even when you play against the Cillian
with white and you get this position you
go for a long castle what's your general
plan where are you going to attack which
lines you're gonna are used to attack
yeah in this position yeah
so you think you know d-file right
that's we can identify that we're going
to pull and e-file
d6 pawn will be a witness right because
the bishop is on a seven right in the
bonus 96 so the bishop is not an e7 as
the more like more common position but
he's on a seven okay do you plan to play
in the center Queen side King side where
we'll be most of the game going
you think Kings side right okay so Jim
thanks King side Center okay so let's
look at the king side so it was
mentioned that Kings side will be one of
the sides where we're going to play the
rukon g8 is off obviously there is no
castle it will remember the chess rules
was the rook moves that's it so most
likely the blacks King option if he
wants to castle will do one side right
maybe 95 then Bishop to d7 and then once
it castle is like this so basically
after identifying that will eliminate
that we're going to really attack on the
King side the King is not going to be
there most likely I know so even I don't
know how the game continues it's used
you show us later but this is kind of
we're trying to analyze that's what
we're doing so if the King castles long
side then most likely the main cast will
be in the center right if the King stays
in the center then center in King side I
don't really see that we're going to
play on the Queen side here once you
figure that out so when you play a game
don't forget to ask yourself a question
once you going to develop all the pieces
you castled
you try to especially it's good when you
don't really know the opening then well
just try to think logical once all the
pieces are developed you're safe you
know
that you didn't wondering if if you
didn't walk into the line that your
opponent used against you to stop and
analyze strategically and after you
create a strategic plan then there is a
tactical part where a good where they're
going to place my thesis how they're
going to implement my strategic plan
which pieces will I need for that so we
can basically apply this theory for any
position after night vd7 so let's
continue queen detail so now you can get
safe 94 is not really a big threat um I
don't really even think that 94 makes
any sense - because Australia the idea
95 right what we're going to we're going
to find it right like this and then it's
nice place g5 what about bishop it's you
opening the D file attacking the d6
right did you calculate that you did
okay so you knew that Queen d2 was a
little provocation right
okay so you played King Boo on here okay
let me let me sink hole
your idea is that after King b1 they
give him a choice either to take on this
free or to take on bv3 he takes b3 take
and then rook most to see one right
that's what you're gonna do okay what if
he takes on d3
what are you going to do then Queen
takes did happen like that in the game
no and you used rather than the pawn on
d6 basically there is no defense because
King g7 is bad defiles not possible
Bishop c5 kind of uncool yeah
kingi sound looks off to me really
awkward in this position and it just
maybe lutely rook e1 and then f2 is
hanging we need to figure that out but
after rook e1 probably 95 will be
stronger but still king of fade after
typically 95 and then font takes one
takes on a King f8 still and meanwhile
he can take enough to with the bishop
the bishop one of trip
but a world I think strategic alia why
it is so much better it's almost like
you can just develop your pieces again
you can put your rook to e1 then you can
play a four or start with a four
actually because the bishop on a selling
is taking the aptitude square just
started with a four so that's pretty
good and then after rook e1 you're going
to threaten efore a5 that's another
option okay so besides that let's return
back to this position so when somebody
plays next if I have an opportunity to
read the knife how do you think do you
calculate first what happens if i take
when c5 how do you guys think
so first you calculate nine takes and
sefa the trade right calculate so here
if we tell it because it's a very
important decision for in moment it's a
kind of every time there is a trade or a
bone structure change it's a very
important moment in the game so you have
to stop and think it's true
first let's see what happens if we take
on c5 Bishop takes right
after Bishop takes button just I think
again continued cleanup for because this
is really complicated rukon g8 and King
Gandhi ate there is no castle here so he
probably wants to develop Bishop to d7
and then cos alongside what if rook e1
safety castles do we have a five here
kind of take take h6
yeah I think we can just even take care
do you have an extra pawn 3 6 5 gm extra
pawn so the only thing on h2 is hanging
to this game on H 294 attacking the
bishop then you have to make a decision
where it put the bishop after this maybe
where do you think we should put the
bishop like v6 think it f8 there are d6
kind of way quiet because it's the play
Bishop to b6 then after 96 check well
right now we can't play there you only
think what I don't like about Bishop of
aid is that it kind of goes back to the
regional square which I'm not a big fan
of that now again it may work because
group on G it's red and G to let it is a
complicated position you have to sit and
calculate everything but we don't
necessarily have to push a 5 but it's
quite normal actually I don't really see
anything really bad for black here do
you see any threat that bothers you
not really right so maybe there's
nothing really that bad
okay so but it's still interesting to
calculate and see yeah we're going to
happen after you trade and is it worth
it and advocacy besides taking on c5 I
don't think that made before is that
strong first of all the knight is not
protected right
another rule remember every time you
pierce it unprotected or you intend to
put your face somewhere where it's not
protected just think twice before that
because you can just miss something and
something and it's always I know it's a
kind of less the rule that you teach the
beginners like watch out for your thesis
so all of them are protected but believe
me it's really useful even when you play
stronger stronger because that's where
often that's where the blunders happen
let's see here if the knight takes in
this rail Queen obviously takes but now
black has two bishops advantage and not
too bad because Bishop d7 and the long
head castle or what we hear the pawn is
hanging right well I don't like bishops
if I may be Bishop d7 we shouldn't play
that move
oh we're just analyzing so yes the
question why we're trying to save the
beach way night yeah which is going over
the lines because this is an important
moment after this moment like if like
Ethan continued King be won the pawn
structure can change or the trade can
occur after that everything going to
change so I want to analyze all the
possible moves it's a very typical
position actually when Knight goes to c5
and offers to trade you should really
eliminate those moves that don't work
and if the bishop wasn't on a
seven-night to d4 it's a very popular
move here because the bishop is on a
seller after 94 it's kind of it's not
protected there and still you have to
watch out there but if the bishop was an
e7 that would have been one of the moves
that you would consider so anyway let's
move on so you play King upon how did he
continue d5 okay so he decided not to
take which probably smart for you from
the Fischer James uh-huh okay so you saw
that constructor before right that was
something that you analyzed before you
analyzed Fischer's games right if he
takes and then you have this open C file
okay okay see you continue d5 code f3
why did you play a free and not F for
every g4 and then you wanted to play h4
okay so here's the reason why I think
this plan again because Sicilian is so
complicated there are so many plants
that you can confuse them there are
different positions so f3 g 4h for can
be awesome when there is opponent g6 and
when the king is Castle it here it's
perfect because once you have black
spawn and g6 then you put on g4 you pawn
an h4 and then you push to h5 works
really well right now imagine your pawns
on g4 in h4 I don't know what we're
going to attack that would be my
objective here because what m27 well it
all depends but he cannot well h6 he
probably can't play because if he plays
h6 then you take on a fix and then the
pawn will be hanging so the point on h6
but it's too slow that's what I can say
Sicilian is a very dynamic opening you
can't just sit in one spot and or maybe
only in a closed system but even in the
closest Illin the risk that attack on
the King side where we have to be very
careful so we can even say that close to
Ceylon it's very sharp opening most of
the times very dynamic the plane slow
it's not very typical for Sicilian all I
can say I would consider playing f4
here instead of upstream that would be
mean but let's see occurring maybe that
worked well for you
then again typical attack a 3G for H or
is when the phone is on g6 for those of
you who play accelerating dragon you
probably know that - well right all
right how did black continue Bishop d7
right okay so he played d5 then she
plays Bishop e7
okay so Bishop takes f6 here it takes
why did you decide to take right here
also there was a combination could we
just play the combination before before
a screen okay let's see take take jack
takes 1955 again another typical
combination this is silly and it's cool
that you saw it so when you think where
it's the best position for the Queen
here
Quinn v6 probably check and then King g7
I don't really see how to advance it do
you guys see any ideas for white
9065 quintic see files okay first night
take the ship okay rook takes all the
sudden the truck is not that bad
attacking the GT phone I think doesn't
work here the compensation all you you
calculating Queen d7 okay yeah but what
if I go here
there's no checkmate
yeah but it's interesting all this sharp
lines like sacrificing b5 that's after a
free okay so maybe that was just another
provocation right why did you decide
that you have to take the knife first
well because you were thinking about the
combination in if we just look at this
line without the combination I wouldn't
really take on it sticks we don't rush
with that but let's see how it worked
for you with the combination uh-huh to
take on d5
okay okay
and thank you five Quintus
so here do you think he calculated that
if he plays couldn't be six then you're
going to continue going to take and then
you're going to take and see five think
you saw that did you see that when
you're forty five minutes time control
so how much time did you have here
fifteen minutes 45 minutes you have for
the gear now you had fifteen minutes so
you spent about 30 minutes for the
opening price okay well usually when you
play 45 minutes in the game depends on
the opening Sicilian if you don't know
the lines you obviously probably going
to spend a lot of time but it's a little
bit too much 30 minutes for the opening
because you have to leave yourself some
time to finish the game yeah if you
happen to calculate some line like this
and you know it's winning it's probably
going to benefit you and 15 minutes will
be enough but it was just a normal play
how many minutes did he have uh-huh so
how much time did you have ten so you
have sixteen here Tex well again it
depends how much time your opponent has
if you have more time than your opponent
then probably that situation is fine too
so how do you guys usually play do play
fast Jim what about you forward so I
like Ethan you spend more time in the
beginning
okay then do you feel like you were you
don't have enough time to finish the
game sometimes order just okay well one
of the good advices about that is just
choose the most logical move especially
when you don't have enough time just
don't calculate in time to the same
variation this is what we all tend to do
we're then to choose a couple lines and
then go back and forth to that line
right and kind of hesitate sure they go
there if you don't see that your way in
the material or your checkmated in that
line then then waste your time
especially if you're sacrificing
something choose the most logical one if
you haven't found anything in ten
minutes thinking most likely nothing's
going to happen in the next five minutes
you're just going to go tell to it over
and over those variations that's just
from my experience obviously when the
super strong brand mattress play is
probably it's different we have to ask
them how they think but are for most
people if you spent enough time to
calculate those lines and didn't find
anything - don't waste your time just
choose the most logical one so here
let's see even how you continue time
curious how did you how did you win
three pawns King g7 can you summon the
ones are 18 d7 did you see that move
before where you were hoping for King f8
good because at least in this position
you should see two more skin be
challenging evade well obviously keen
can go to D file 95 how did she respond
going b6 he played okay so commence
Queen d7 any other options here let's
think takes pegs
then 95 here how are you going to win
this position did you see that yeah so
you were going for this position right
how are you going to draw this well but
look at the look at the rooks I'm going
to bring the rook to be aid and now your
king will be under it up or I mean on GT
this rook is actually fine you're going
to play a rook a to be aid and then
another rope from g8 is going to just
get a stroke up here and this rook comes
here okay well here actually I don't
really like this Bishop of six anymore
you know you know why imagine the bishop
on g5 guys and then you pawned from me
for will be able to attack the bush to
e5 and there will be a pin I don't like
this I like how it happening again that
you trapped him and he didn't find the
right move I don't like taking an f6 we
need to calculate that without taking of
six maybe that makes better sense did
you have to generalize that on your
computer so instead of Bishop takes of
six you should have played Bishop take
the five the line that we analyzed right
away right okay let's see what your
computer tone uh-huh Quincy six okay
King g7 okay King of 8/9 to a 500mb six
a c4 then maybe even take here okay
Quinn was here that's a good position to
play let's say against a friend right
because you know guys the most
complicated part it's winning the
winning position right how many times we
get the winning position and then we're
like gay with so much better
when it comes to the green part for
making steaks because usually when we
prepare for the game when we train we'll
never play the positions where we just
went in right looking oh we're just much
better or I'm a pawn up I'm fine here so
that's why it's very useful to place her
in positions even when you know you're
kind of winning play against a friend
and try to win it
what if I play here mm-hmm
your hopefully here what would you do
does it make sense to go back I'm not
sure c4 here beautiful rukon g8 right
isn't it hello from the opening yeah
it's kind of getting awkward here 97 is
bad
97 here negative 7
and for persons well room the six here
the night is hanging you play right here
or later you mean after room the six
right here and then we'll get six and
then there is very the trap a person who
likes tactics just wonderful setup any
time the player who like sharp games can
sacrifice and d5 they just so happy I
don't really think that they calculated
the last move they just feel bad so if
an any more tactical player or what
should you like technical positions
right okay so you just do the rules
because you felt that sacrificing device
can bring benefit I think that if you
manage to play the Krug this six right
but you should keep in mind actually
that was a little religious question why
do we sacrifice enough seven because
we're sacrificing and not appears note
will really sacrifice one and then we're
two pieces down and you should innocent
one to sacrifice your opponent can start
sacrificing back in order to save his
position so that that's quite legit
question can we avoid taking enough
seven maybe we can just bring the Queen
there and attack all they're selling fun
I don't - the either
so Quinn a force to take in the seven I
think much stronger thank you for the
question
yeah it's it's actually a after night
after Queen of core you guys should
consider nice tasty seven night takes be
7 and then route this salad as well
it's one of the options but really
Bishop on c5 shouldn't take enough sick
besides 95 what else can he do 97 and
then you play 24 again how we going to
protect so if she plays 97 you playin 84
how is he going to defend f7 square
what's he going to do I just don't see
anything again we just come to the same
situation was you get the knight in the
south on the 6 Kuna for it's typical
combination how it works it's also one
of the French defense ideas 926 and
Queen Anne for Albert white when I was
when I was a little kid there were some
lines I remember that the world like
this no I was never a French defence
player but I played with white against
French defense and then I remember when
I was a little girl with this plane I
don't normally there was 7 8 years old
I had some lines like this like the
knife comes to the safe then you bring
the Queen to f4 so this is the structure
so
it returned back here the Quincy six is
the only move right according to the
computer and according to our analysis
probably clean to six is the only move
then you take one to six King g7 you
played 95 ok going to be six you had the
same position but without the bishop on
g5 right Bishop takes and then opponent
was taken of six even here in five
that's the beauty of having the bishop
on g5 this ePHI threat is really liliom
well that was a very nice game and I
think that so you didn't know the
sacrifice before to journalize that so
you came up with that decision at the
board right well playing the game
oh that's great that's because usually
if you don't play this variation and you
don't see if you can't analyze many
players don't take on d5 because they
kind of didn't prepare that but that's
pretty pretty cool that you decided to
go for that line does anybody have
questions about this game so Ethan thank
you very much for sharing your game
thank you and that this should be five
was really awesome since you never saw
that it's truly great you found it and
congratulations of beating the higher
rating opponent it feels really good
once you beat somebody hydrated right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]